chérie allez oh je vais aux gens je suis
content frérot Benjamin Castaldi c'est
pour ça voilà il vient nous voir pour
nous présenter sa pièce de théâtre
bungalow 21 qui fait déjà un carton sera
du mercredi au samedi à 21h et le samedi
à 16h au Théâtre de la Madeleine
les poussières il raconte la vraie
histoire de ses grands-parents Yves
Montand
et Simone Signoret il est là Benjamin
Castaldi
[Applaudissements]
ça va
on sait très souvent au téléphone
tous les jours quasiment ou par SMS et
cet été je l'ai souvent eu mon chéri
comment ça va super bien je suis très
performant tu as un magnifique costume
alors pour les bonnes habitudes vas-y
vas-y en même temps mais c'est mieux que
de déguisé en mécano si tu veux je peux
te faire la vidange ça fait plaisir en
tout cas on est très heureux de te voir
mon chéri je te voulais lundi et je
savais pas et de venir je te veux lundi
direct vous m'avez dit 20h10 ça a changé
voilà mais ça change tout hein
t'inquiète pas rien dit que tu resteras
pas jusqu'à 20h10 donc je peux te dire
que tu fasses
bungalow 21 du mercredi au samedi à 21h
le samedi à 16h et tu nous en a parlé
ici c'était ton projet c'est vraiment je
suis tellement heureux que ça arrive et
que enfin ça arrive au théâtre parce que
Benjamin il nous en parle depuis
peut-être deux ans tu m'en parles ah
ouais ça fait 4 ans même moi deux ans
que tu m'en parles mais c'est vrai en
fait pendant le confinement le premier
et non je suis très heureux franchement
de cette pièce avec Emmanuel et Mathilde
Seigner c'est de Eric Emmanuel Schmitt
mise en scène par Jérémy Lippmann on va
regarder l'abandon tu vas nous raconter
ce qui se passe est-ce que tu as fait
c'est parti bienvenue au bungalow 20
scandale à Hollywood le couple le plus
célèbre numérique n'existe plus Arthur
Miller et Marilyn momro divorce suite au
tournage du film Le Milliardaire rumeur
d'une liaison avec la star française
Yves Montand va bon train
[Musique]
mais que s'est-il passé derrière les
murs du bungalow 21 du Beverly Hills
cette histoire dépasse largement le
petit monde des studios hollywoodiens
le scandale se répand comme une traînée
de poudre jusqu'au rue de Paris un
scandale Yves Montand Marily
spécial à partir de septembre 2023 au
Théâtre de la Madeleine
[Musique]
à partir
et bah ça y est donc et ça cartonne ça
va pas mal ça marche très fort
elle avait envie d'être avec lui il
devait rester 3 mois ensemble il y a une
grève comme il y a maintenant d'ailleurs
Hollywood du coup il y a ça a pris du
retard elle est partie à Rome faire un
film entre temps elle est l'Oscar et il
allait la laisser son mari avec Marilyn
Monroe et généralement dans ces cas-là
voilà c'est boulettes
voilà donc du coup voilà il a dit quand
on est avec mariamaro c'est rare qu'on
est dans la salle de bain donc
si vous faites un film avec Margot
Robbie vous par exemple pas du tout
alors je sais pas moi avec qui par
exemple avec toi
avec toi ça peut me chauffer et donc
c'est vrai qu'il est voilà il y a une
liaison ça c'est sûr et bref c'est que
ma grand-mère voilà elle l'a appris elle
a été la cocu la plus célèbre du monde
puisque le monde entier l'après il y a
eu toute la presse du monde entier de
l'Italie à Tokyo en passant par voilà et
ça a été terrible pour elle je raconte
c'est ça que je raconte voilà et mon
temps il a essayé de
le morceau mais il a fait beaucoup de
mal voilà donc c'est à la fois très
drôle bon c'est la fois très drôle parce
que mon temps il avait beaucoup d'humour
il avait il avait un une mauvaise foi
absolument incroyable quand il dit à sa
femme enfin franchement maintenant plus
depuis que je suis avec elle elle est
jamais en retard sur le plateau de
tournage faut qu'elle osé dire ça sa
femme et voilà donc c'est on est très
fier c'est une très belle pièce et
j'espère que les jeunes vont venir parce
qu'il y a pas mal de de personnes de
plus de 50 qui viennent parce qu'ils
connaissent ce soir mais franchement il
faudrait que les avec les moins de 30
voisins parce que c'est voilà moins de
20 voilà Daniel va y aller
quoi tu connaissais cette histoire bien
sûr et oui en fait c'est vraiment un peu
le début de la fin pour pour
le début de du reste parce que après cet
épisode elle a fait une deuxième
carrière elle a fait tous les grands
films le chat la même Couderc on peut le
dire c'est toi qui a eu l'idée de
comment s'est passé donc c'est toi qui
en fait j'étais avec mon camarade
Philippe sol que tu que tu connais qui
m'a dit tu devrais tu deviens un amour
il m'a dit tu devrais essayer de monter
quelque chose autour de cette histoire
on a fait un petit dossier comme on fait
comme on est étudiant j'ai dit qui on
pourrait demander de décrire la pièce
j'ai été voir Smith j'ai mis un an avant
le rendez-vous les cuisines
il m'a dit ça peut m'intéresser il s'est
fait attendre il m'a dit une fois deux
fois je vous rappelle trois fois je vous
rappelle et à la fin du premier
confinement il m'a dit viens à la maison
et on s'est enfermé une semaine dans la
cuisine
on s'est enfermé chez lui et donc voilà
je lui ai amener tous les documents que
j'avais personnel et la correspondance
du coup
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
donc c'est toi qui a c'est toi qui a une
idée bah oui je te l'ai dit déjà deux
fois qui produit ou pas je comprends
on parle de producteurs à producteur là
tu t'en sors ça va c'est une belle
saison
une belle journée
mais bon c'est si tu as
je peux vous dire si je vous dis ça ça
va être un carton c'est la pièce de la
rentrée et je suis tellement heureux
pour Benji c'est toi qui a choisi
Mathilde Seigner ah Mathilde je voulais
absolument mais elle voulait aller 4 ans
pour la convaincre et c'est elle qui a
eu l'idée d'engager sa sœur c'était un
pari culotté mais du coup elle est ils
sont tous incroyable
Vincent incroyable Clément Moreau
vraiment je vais tous les soirs je fais
tous les soirs avec eux c'est mon bébé
donc je vois évoluer je on a donné des
conseils de mise en scène ou pas du tout
non non j'étais comment tu voyais les
choses j'ai dit moi j'étais le garant un
peu du temps pour mes grands-parents
donc il fallait pas que l'image de mes
grands-parents me dérange et là je suis
très content et voilà c'est franchement
je suis extrêmement fier ouais tous les
soirs le temps que ça se voilà quand ça
sera quand ce sera quand ça roulera tu
fais ça donc là c'est ton projet numéro
1 numéro 1 et puis après tu as d'autres
projets ah non qu'est-ce que vous voulez
[Applaudissements]
et là c'est là maintenant et à la
Première Chaîne d'Europe on ne citera
pas qui a des gros problèmes d'audience
non et ils se disent pourquoi est-ce
qu'on relance pas une télé-réalité comme
on en a fait une il y a 20 ans il
rappelle le producteur qui avait fait le
succès de la chaîne il y a 20 ans et
nous ça alors c'est oui c'est chez vous
le programme je vous ai pas révolé
et donc
et après il relance une télé réalité qui
va très mal se passer voilà ouais
ça c'est en développement ces signaux
pour toi mon chéri et tu nous manques je
te le dis mais vous manquez aussi
dis-nous la vérité quand tu vois arriver
18h40 est-ce que tu as une petite
rassera bah évidemment d'abord je suis
devant ma télé très souvent
alors je voudrais dire lui c'est un mec
mais je l'aime il le sait que je l'aime
et que et non mais ça manquait mais
j'étais honnêtement quand je vois
l'émission et quand je vois de ce quoi
vous ce dont vous parlez franchement je
suis mieux chez moi franchement tu le
sens pas du tout
c'est le chagate qui t'a le chaga mais
le chat m'a pas échaudé mais mais toi
même la série il a fait une série sur la
télé donc c'était honnêtement je l'ai
dit et c'est vrai que on va se mentir
les ces derniers mois voilà je t'ai payé
rien fou de bon ben je l'ai dit et il a
dit il a tellement raison
[Rires]
d'être là et juste être là pour pour on
a fait le tour de mes femmes de mes
dettes de mes petits yeux de mes seins
on va te laisser avoir des nouvelles
fans des nouvelles voilà ok et tu seras
toujours le bienvenu mon chéri et non
mais si t'es heureux moi je suis très
heureux pour toi et vraiment mon bendy
c'est vrai que moi je te rappelle de ta
première dans TPMP ah oui enfin je me
rappelle oui 5 septembre 2016 par rappel
tu vas la revoir ouais c'est vrai ouais
c'est des images à moi donc c'est
gratuit
et le félicité il vit un amour fusionnel
voilà et ça nous fait plaisir parce
qu'il est très en forme et la bonne
nouvelle est vraiment je suis très très
heureux de ça c'est que Benjamin
Castaldi rejoint l'équipe de Touche pas
à mon poste
ça va mon chéri d'amour merci d'être là
mon ange merci Monsieur c'est très
content
[Musique]
bon les séries bon Benjamin est-ce que
tu es content d'être avec nous j'étais
un peu long un peu la tente mais c'est
bien
remarié j'ai vu dans le dans le parcours
ici 7 ans avec nous dans TPMP et à tous
les gens qui t'ont côtoyé tu as laissé
des souvenirs tout mon thème c'est vrai
que ce soit les équipes techniques la
prod la sécu les journalistes figure-toi
que ce soir certains d'entre eux ont
voulu partager un souvenir marquant
qu'ils ont vécu avec toi je te propose
des découvrir ils vont s'afficher dans
l'écran dis-moi lesquels tu veux écouter
en premier on a donc on a Mokhtar
Mokhtar donc voilà Moktar il est pas là
d'accord Sacha se produit pas fait qui
produisait le 6 à 7 Sixtine qui s'occupe
des chroniqueurs et qui comme vous
voulez voler et Adèle qui s'occupe du
partenariat et des cas est-ce que tu
veux
par ordre saloperies je vais prendre
Adèle comme ça j'en ai marre de tout de
suite
Benjamin j'espère que tu vas bien j'ai
énormément de souvenirs avec toi
énormément bon on va pas revenir sur les
bouquets de fleurs que tu récupérais
pour les donner à ta femme au moment de
la Saint-Valentin on va pas revenir non
plus sur la trottinette les trois
trottinettes électriques que tu m'as
demandé mais moi mon plus beau souvenir
avec toi il est récent il y avait par
exemple le séjour le séjour que tu m'as
demandé dans un parc d'attraction pour
ta famille
l'organisation de ton déménagement
franchement ça c'était sympathique j'ai
que de très très bons souvenirs avec toi
en tout cas je te souhaite plein de
bonnes choses pour la suite à plus tard
Ciao
alors tout est vrai
effectivement c'était le parc qu'on ne
citera pas voilà c'était pour mes
enfants sur bien sûr voilà mais comme il
était parti à l'émission pourquoi on
peut en profiter quand on déménagement
ça coûte un bras et quand je passe mon
temps à déménager tous les six mois au
bout du 5e j'ai dit il faut que je
trouve
on verra ça peut encore
changerai pour rien voilà
toujours tu sais que ouais soit toujours
alors tu veux écouter quelqu'un d'autre
alors là ça doit être Moctar
[Rires]
tous les jours vous voulez taper avec
moi tous les jours tous les jours parce
qu'il a sur un
petit décor
sur ce que tu dis frère tu as été moi ça
à la Tour d'Argent quoi frère
c'est quoi ce resto de ouf
forte
oseille
Benjamin donc là tu vas faire la pièce
ouais tu prépares ta série et on télé
qu'est-ce que tu as envie de faire
monter dis-nous la vérité parce que je
sais que tu es un fou de télé arrête non
mais j'ai pas dit que j'aurais pu
t'aider mais faut que je refasse de je
suis pas des je pourrais faire des gros
barnums moi des gros barnum genre quoi
je refais genre des nouvelles stars des
trucs comme ça
du direct plutôt parce que c'est il y a
quand même ça qui c'est quand même ça le
lecteur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je suis pas très bon chroniqueur
[Rires]
je pense et donc là tu aimerais faire
quoi tu aimerais aller sur quelle chaîne
honnêtement je veux celle qui
m'accueille vraiment est-ce que tu as
pris de rendez-vous avec des chaînes non
non non
mais tu seras au courant en plus
je crois que j'ai tu crois oui il y a
dehors
c'est bon
j'ai la maison
là je voulais vraiment me concentrer sur
ça et en janvier on verra on verra alors
si tu veux j'en viens à l'antenne c'est
maintenant
mais là j'ai rien envie de faire là j'ai
envie de faire un jeu toi
comme jeu un contre 100 et c'est chez
vous
un contre-sens
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça marche pas des masses
on n'est pas au mieux avec eux
[Rires]
donc le patron des programmes c'est
Xavier tu crois
tout le monde
c'est comme ça il y a pas de mémoire à
la télé n'a pas de mémoire je te le dis
ne crois pas ça si tu étais bon donc tu
es bon donc ils ont besoin de toi trois
mois bah si je te le dis je te le dis
c'est pas gagné sur ça et sur une
plateforme pourquoi moi c'est ce que je
moi si j'étais toi ce que j'aurais fait
je te voilà je vais te donner je vais te
donner voilà
cadeau c'est cadeau je te le dis un jeu
sur plateforme il faut que tu fasses un
jeu sur une plateforme le premier gros
jeu sur une plateforme je te le dis ça
va être un carton crois-moi maintenant
c'est ça qu'il faut que tu fasses arrête
avec les chaînes de télé les chaînes de
télé CP que tu vas faire sur TF1
qu'est-ce qui se passe TF1 il se passe
rien tu vois bien qu'il se passe rien ça
me va pas m'arranger ce qu'on dit là
tout de suite
oh non sur une plateforme ou bien même
mettre des chaussures plateformes
ah non mais très bien fort mais bien sûr
que c'est vrai je ne rigole pas
aujourd'hui vous produisez un jeu sur la
plateforme mais vas-y moi avec plaisir
c'est pas moi
c'est vrai regardez vérités
je te jure parce que Ben excellent et
vous êtes content de le voir
est-ce que ça va lui dire dites-nous oui
faire la porte-parole des chroniqueurs
on sait tous dit et on se le dit presque
tous les jours fin du mois à chaque fois
que je suis là que tu nous manques donc
que ton sourire du manque que tes
solaires
dans les couloirs
nous a dit bah si vous voulez on le paye
à venir dans les couloirs
vous avez un grand respect pour moi
quand même hein
mais c'est pour la darka genre tu dois
faire des darks avec nous il veut pas
faire la télé tu
restes mais vraiment tu veux que toi
frère tu viens dans les trucs tu passes
tu viens quand même
tu viens tu repars on fait un ping-pong
tu perds 50 balles tu rentres en fait
Benjamin tous les soirs en fait tous les
soirs on t'attend on attend
tous les soirs on attend que tu arrives
qu'est-ce qu'il va dire attends attends
attends attends
il va falloir qu'on parle de la Coupe
parce qu'on dirait que tu as un
cerf-volant sur la tête
on se retrouve